[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace norte américa desde
miami se cumplen casi 7 meses de una
tragedia que conmocionó al sur de la
florida y al resto del mundo tras el
desplome de un condominio ahora la
controversia está en qué pasará con ese
terreno
los desarrolladores hacen sus mejores
ofertas para adquirirlo porque ahora el
mercado de bienes raíces en florida vive
su particular época dorada am en este
programa también comentaremos como miami
se ha convertido en la ciudad de moda
durante la pandemia del cob y 19 que ha
afectado al mundo
el 24 de junio de 2021 98 personas
perdieron la vida tras desplomarse un
edificio en este lugar en sarsfied
colindante a la ciudad de miami beach la
mayoría de los fallecidos quedaron
atrapados bajo los escombros de hierro y
hormigón los que sobrevivieron cuentan
que lo que vivieron esa noche fue una
auténtica pesadilla fueron momentos muy
malos
que a veces a uno nada no lo quieren y
recordar verdad escuchábamos personas
que estaban llorando y gritando por
ayuda pero en realidad ahora pienso no
sé si eran los mismos que murieron o
personas vecinos de allí o los mismos de
los pisos me entienden pero yo recuerdo
bastante los estruendos fueron más de
cuatro semanas de intensa búsqueda
primero con la esperanza de encontrar
supervivientes y después conscientes de
que eso sería imposible
los trabajos se intensificaron para dar
con los cadáveres y que sus familiares
al menos pudieran cerrar este capítulo
mi esposo estaba adentro ahí y yo no
sabía realmente qué era lo que pasaba yo
lo miraba
ambulancia bombero policía y todo eso
pero yo todavía no sabía realmente qué
era lo que pasaba yo me enteré hasta
después que entré en la 'zona cero'
autoridades federales de eeuu continúan
con la investigación para esclarecer qué
fue lo que causó el derrumbe pero la
polémica va mucho más allá sobre todo
porque ahora hay un debate sobre si se
debe construir o no un nuevo edificio
familiares y sobrevivientes creen que
este sitio se convierte en un memorial
para recordar a las víctimas de ese
fatídico día sería bueno que se
construyera un memorial ahí porque
fueron muchas personas que fallecieron y
muchas familiares de ellos están allí en
ese en esa en esa misma zona si yo
pienso que este sería construir un
memorial un recuerdo sí
porque eso
allí pasó a
198 muertos
entre niños
ángeles que encienden es triste y si
gracias a dios no pasó pero ahí
estuviera yo también hay mucho interés
en comprar ese terreno y construir un
nuevo edificio el mercado inmobiliario
en el sur de la florida vive su mejor
momento y ese sitio se ha convertido en
un bien muy codiciado la zona de
surfside hay una gran demanda y falta de
terrenos para desarrollar con lo cual
hay una gran presión por parte de los
desarrolladores de conseguir este
terreno este lote y cualquier lote
porque hay una gran falta de terrenos
disponibles los agentes inmobiliarios
como pilar no dejan de recibir llamadas
de potenciales clientes en busca de
propiedades muchos son de california
nueva york que quieren mudarse porque
ahora por la pandemia pueden trabajar a
distancia y tener mejores condiciones de
vida el kobe ha traído mucha gente que
se ha mudado a florida y también el
teletrabajo esta gente que han venido
sobre todo desde el norte de eeuu han
llegado aquí se han quedado gracias al
buen nivel de vida el buen clima y las
prestaciones que ofrece florida
y eso ha provocado que irremediablemente
los precios se hayan disparado en
algunos casos en más del 50% en menos de
dos años
la previsión para los próximos años es
que sigan subiendo los precios de las
propiedades sobre todo por la falta de
inventario miami se ha convertido de la
ciudad de moda durante la pandemia aquí
prácticamente no ha habido restricciones
y el sector turístico se ha beneficiado
de ello miami se convirtió en un oasis
durante el año de la pandemia para los
norteamericanos el gobierno de la
florida la verdad es que pensó en cómo
iba a afectar esto en los negocios y en
ese sentido dentro de las posibilidades
siempre siendo precavido
abrió mucho las restricciones para que
los negocios pudieron sobrevivir por lo
menos el golpe económico no ha sido tan
duro para el sector turístico del sur de
la florida como se pronosticaba en un
principio ahora esta zona se ha
convertido en un destino que ofrece
mucho más que fiesta y buen clima y en
realidad tenemos mucho que ofrecer
antes miami estaba reconocida
simplemente como sol y playas hoy miami
es un centro muy importante de negocios
es un centro muy importante de
compañías que tienen sus divisiones de
latinoamérica localizada aquí el idioma
ayuda mucho la situación geográfica
también y bueno pues miami en la meca
del turismo y de negocio hoy en día aquí
comerciantes y turistas agradecen que
por lo menos miami se haya convertido en
una vía de escape en medio del
coronavirus hablar desde aquí en miami
absolutamente nadie son mascarillas es
increíble ar parecida que no tiene
hubiera pandemia entonces no sé qué
estará pasando pero en el gobierno del
problema que está bien aunque esa falta
de medidas antiguo por sus consecuencia
ya que en varias ocasiones florida se
convirtió en el epicentro de la pandemia
pero parece que importaba más la
economía que la salud de la población
hasta aquí enlace norteamérica gracias
por sintonizarnos y recuerde que para
ver de nuevo este programa puede visitar
nuestro sitio web fresh 24 punto com
hasta la próxima